こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
天気が悪いね
なんか最近天気が悪くてさ
なんか、こう、パッとしないんですけども～
お前たち
味噌汁とかさカップ麺を作るときどうやって作ってる？
水道水か
あっ、水道水を沸かして使うのね
うーん、なるほどなるほど…
バープ！！！！！
バープだよ！！
バープの意味がわかんないけど
いつでもさ、そーゆー水道水があると思うんじゃねえぞ
緊急時にはな
水が無くなることだってあるんだよ
だから今日はな
お前たちにな
もしこのなんか水道とかさ
この天然水とかさ
こう、普段気軽に使える
安心した水が無いときの
対処法をオレが今日教えようと思う
というわけで今日はですね
あの、雨が降ってるんで今から
雨水で味噌汁を作って飲めるかどうか確かめてみようと思います
お前たち甘えすぎなんだよ
いつでもな
安心で安全で飲める水があると思うんじゃねぇぞ
綺麗な水っていうのはな
作るのにとーっても大変なんだ
たぶん。
本来あるべき味だよ　それが
やっぱ自然の味を楽しまないとダメだと思うんで
というわけで
雨、採ってくる
実はな
ちょー怖いんだよ
というわけで
あのバケツ…あﾔﾍﾞﾔﾍﾞ
というわけでバケツ…じゃないや
フライパン用意したんで
しばらくこんな感じで集めまーす
はい
俺死なねえかな
屋根のあの雨水が収束する部分から落ちている雨水をとります
よりなんかあれですね
危険な感じがします
見えるかな
結構溜まりました
いやっ、案外ねぇ
イケそうっすよ
ちょっと透明なコップで汲んでみましょう
肉眼で確認できますでしょうか
なにかが渦巻いております
あっ、これはわかりやすい
なーんかねぇ
ちょいちょい浮いてるんですよ
うーわ　マジか
マジかーー
思ったより汚い
マジかー
いやけどもう飲むって言ったんで僕はもう作りますよ
はい！というわけで
雨水で
味噌汁を作って飲もうと思います
俺これ死なないよね！？
イヤだわ～
イヤになってきたわ～
雨水セット
雨水異常なし
雨水点火
雨水範囲！高温注意！
雨水異常なし
浮遊物発見…
あ、雨水異常なし
俺これ思ったんだけど今さ
結構沸騰でさ殺菌できると思うんだよね
意外とイケるんじゃね？
なあ
これ上手いよなあ
おお、なんか出てきてるぞ
おおおお、よいよい
きたきたきた
なんか違うところ燃えてね？
これなんかおかしいよね
なんか違うとこ燃えてるよね
まあ、いっか
やばいやばい
なんかおかしい
どっちかというと　あれだ
フライパンの下から出てる
やっぱ…目でもわかるね
なにか浮いてるのが
これはなんなんだろうね
これが出てるってことはもう完璧に
多分完全に熱されてますね
はい次味噌汁を作ります
しじみです
しじみを作ろう
しじみ、入りました
あとはお湯を入れて完成です(もぐもぐ)
これはこぼしたら死ぬ
これはこぼしたら死ぬやつだ
よし、着地
いやー、これこぼしたら死ぬねぇ
あーーー　やばい
あるある
ぉうわーー
お湯あるあるだ
お湯あるある
よしよし、よし
できました、できました
とりあえず、とりあえず、ちょ、これを
とりあえずこれを片付けてこよう
あー、これダメだ
危ないやつだ
これダメだ…
ｱﾁｬｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰ
はい　というわけでなんとかできました
パッと見はね意外と普通の味噌汁です
うん。普通。
普通、普通、普通
いたって普通
ま、でも見た目じゃないのは
百も承知なんでね
ま、パパっと食っちゃいましょう
いやでも大丈夫だよね
変な病気とかならないよね
いただきやす
なんだろう
意外とイケるんだよね
意外とイケます　これ
うん。意外とイケるんで(もぐもぐ)
ホントはね　こう食ったら
マズくて
ｽｰｰ   ｩｵｴｯ  ﾏｽﾞｲｯｯ
っていうね
きれいなオチを想像してたんですけど
そうでもなかったんで
オチは特にないです
あのローソンのミルフィーユおいしいんで
ぜひ食べてみてください